[Music]
tonight you're going to teach me we're
going to Ratchet it up you're gonna
teach me to defend myself against common
weapons like guns and knives is that
right we're gonna raise the stakes big
time that we're all in on this show good
defense you shouldn't do that okay so I
don't have the gun it's very serious if
someone had a gun pointed now wasn't the
first thing to do to say whatever you
want
absolutely if we're if we're three feet
apart or even more there's really
nothing you can do other than you know
psychologically get into the guy move
around a little bit and then scurry out
that's all you can really do there's not
much you can do from this position
scurry out yeah but if we're in tight if
we're in close if I'm within your
critical distance critical yeah now you
have a chance this is the cone zone
right you know what you're doing that
the good chaps some ask a question if
someone's far away with a gun I should
maybe try and get them closer right get
them closer or you get out one or the
other well let's say I can't get out
okay but you've got the gun and you're
further away no no you have the gun I
should be like oh that's a cool gun
those are cool I'd like to see it a
little closer right it may work on some
people okay a lot of people who have
guns are proud of their guns so yeah
let's try this out let's go through a
scenario already bad guy I'm the bad guy
I got you now ho
so what time is it what time is it
Oh whoa okay
so let's break that down that was
incredible you you ask you you distract
it you asked me what time it was I got
you off your original intention to shoot
me I got you thinking about something
else right and then once you're
distracted we could execute the
technique which is pretty simple just
moving off to the side grabbing the
muzzle right and then feel this yeah
yeah I feel that yeah yeah that's the
one muscle I have yeah and you squeeze
that and that made me really cinch back
like that you have the gun and reverse
and then clear yourself so now you're
out of the critical distance own yeah
but then I use my feet and then I
apologize okay try this on Ben oh you
don't do it you bring in Ben okay okay
then how are you you want to get right
into a scenario I'm being robbed by a
soccer star I guess okay all right so
he's in your zone and I'm just saying
and I gotta distract him right he's
gonna probably say give me all your
money use the home now Oh
you like caramel corn
[Applause]
not bad you got the gun away from my own
trouble yeah I think in real life he'd
grab the gun back before I could but
okay what is that this is a simulated
knife because you're not gonna use a
real knife obviously thank you okay
we're gonna pretend this is the knife
okay knife defense is really tricky
a lot of self-defense people will teach
you how to do it you know like a really
crazy block and something fancy the
disarm it's not gonna work because in
reality no one's gonna strike you
exactly the way you planned it and knife
to knife people who are attacking are
not gonna attack you with just one
strike they're gonna do like a bunch of
their crimes of passion so it goes
quickly you can't prepare for it
[Applause]
[Music]
so first off your lateral that was an
expensive shirt I've walked away from
worse though
so you just stabbed me I mean first of
all your killer is like but that's
that's how it happens huh what's gonna
happen now can you pass against that
number one you didn't have lateral
movement right you said you did but you
went backwards so I didn't know we were
gonna do that
exactly most people before they kill you
say I'm gonna kill you now